have you like me always dreamed of
playing Mario Zelda and we tennis on
your mobile well it looks like these
dreams are set to come true as Nintendo
as an ice that it's gonna make mobile
games also I really need to stop
dreaming about Wii tennis the beloved
games giant has struck a major
partnership with Japanese smartphone
games developer DNA here's the crux
Nintendo has signed a deal with DNA
which means both companies will jointly
create new games featuring Nintendo
intellectual property specifically for
smart devices Mario and mobile Samus on
Samsung why are your Windows Phone it's
all very possible all of a sudden except
maybe that last one alongside this
Nintendo also confirmed its plans to
create what it's calling a core system
that serves a variety of devices
including PCs smartphones and tablets as
well as in tendons dedicated videogame
systems it's not clear exactly how this
works but it's like Lima Nintendo is in
fact referring to a digital service that
unites these systems at a press
conference on Tuesday chief executive
Satoru Iwata said that the new
membership service will encompass the
existing Nintendo 3ds and WiiU systems
as well as a new hardware system
codenamed the NX keep your eyes on games
bought for more on this as part of this
deal Nintendo's bought 10% of DNA while
the mobile games publisher has acquired
1.2 4% of Nintendo so tell me what do
you make of this news and what Nintendo
games are you dying to play on your
mobile tablets or even your phablet let
me know in the comments down below and
for all other Nintendo news come on back
to GameSpot
you